oh get wrecked boom double Q is the
iPhone 14 pro Max a better phone for
gaming than the s22 ultra from Samsung
well that is exactly the question that
I'm gonna answer in this video and I'm
gonna focus on three main things average
FPS the battery life and display dimming
as you can see I have both of them set
to the same settings with Bluetooth off
adaptive display brightness turned off I
matched up the brightness on both of
them using the top camera to make sure
they're both at the same amount of knits
and as you can see they're both plugged
into this MacBook Pro at a hundred
percent battery life and the reason I
have this MacBook Pro setup right here
is because I am using Wii Test's perfdog
FPS counter which basically you plug in
one of these smartphones and it measures
the average FPS the CPU usage and more
so we can track exactly the FPS that we
got in each of the game games that we
play because we're playing three
different games for one hour each and
after each hour we're gonna see the
battery life on each phone and with that
said let's go ahead and start with the
Galaxy s22 Ultra all right now as you
can see we are starting at 142 so one
hour from now we're gonna come back and
there you go let's turn on our FPS
counter now that we're in the game and
just to show you guys the graphic
settings we have very high and set to
Max it looks like we were actually
sitting there at 30 FPS in the menu so
I'm actually gonna turn this off and
just restart it again as soon as the
game starts to make sure it's Gathering
the average FPS correctly there you go
we're in game 60fps just started the
counter all right here we go
oh snap
by the way this is ranked should be a
little bit more difficult of course I
love how this tiny little camera
cut out you could barely see it so this
entire time we've been sitting between
59 and 60 FPS so perfect no issues so
far right there's you some guys up here
gotcha Avenger shouldn't have turned
around buddy I'm gonna try to play about
20 minutes of this game total before I
get onto the next one perfect oh I do
see a couple of frame drops right there
in terms of the FPS a little bit and by
the way if you guys enjoy that 60 FPS
video quality go ahead and subscribe for
more videos like this now one of the
things that bugs me is that it's easy to
block the speaker Port right here
like like that if you're holding it
which is kind of annoying especially
since the bottom speaker is quite a bit
louder and then the earpiece
now one thing I don't really like about
this phone is that the edges are kind of
Corners are boxy so you can't really
wrap your finger around it that easily I
guess so it's not as comfortable
was that a double knife
boom double Q
what what Get Wrecked another one all
right there you go that game was about
15 or so minutes so I'm just gonna go
ahead and stop
this and I have the data file right here
for Call of Duty but I'm gonna wait
until the conclusion to show you guys
the difference and now let's move over
to the iPhone let's go ahead and unplug
it for the battery life test and let's
get right into Cod mobile let's go ahead
and turn on the FPS tracker right there
and as you can see our time is at 3 23
so one hour from now we're gonna stop it
and look at the FPS oh those speakers
are good okay right off the bat I can
hear better quality speakers and of
course you see the big pill-shaped cut
out right over there much more intrusive
than the s22 ultra's little camera haul
oh and I forgot to show you guys the
graphic settings as you can see very
high in Max just like the s22 ultra
now I am noticing that the earpiece
speaker is for sure louder than on the
s22 now honestly it does kind of seem
like the
FPS is kind of
not perfectly smooth to be honest
yeah there you go not too bad it's not
perfect 60 it might actually be worse
than the s22 ultra so far
still at maximum brightness no dimming
yet and just like the s22 it does go
down to 30 FPS for the menu so that will
impact the average FPS a bit now one
thing I do like about the iPhone
compared to the s22 is that you have
these rounded Corners compared to the
boxy corners on the s22 so it kind of
like wraps around your finger and it's
more convenient to hold kind of like a
game controller honestly
you did
we running everywhere we ain't stopping
still we got some variants from the FPS
around 55 to 60. so surprisingly it
seems like it's not as smooth as the s22
brightness still maxed out I'm not
seeing any dimming
okay
yeah triple cool
man I'm starting to feel
it up just a little bit
[Music]
oh
50 to 10. that's what I'm talking about
brightness still great oh 92 rating and
there you go that was almost 20 minutes
in COD mobile so let's go ahead and
pause this right here turn that off now
getting into the next game on the s22
ultra we have League of Legends wild
Rift there we go let's turn on the FPS
counter right there go into the graphic
settings as you can see we have it set
to custom 60fps super high on the
graphics quality post processing on
effects high and dynamic resolution off
so it doesn't adjust it if it needs to
we're gonna put the most amount of
stress on this and let's do some Aram
and now I'm starting to feel the s22
ultra get a little bit hot on the back
so it seems like it's getting a good
load on it so far we're sitting at a
solid 60 FPS which is expected for this
game keep in mind the last game I'm
gonna play is ganshin impact which is
the most demanding so don't forget about
that look at that perf dog it's been
basically solid 60 FPS
non-stop no dimming so far in this phone
which is great and it doesn't even feel
that hot the interesting thing is
definitely going to be the battery life
hands down
he destroyed me
got me doing a quick brightness checkup
still at maximum brightness no issues oh
come on let's go
oh we did it look at that comeback we
don't surrender boom MVP for triple
kills come on man yeah all right so that
was almost 20 minutes on wild riff let's
go ahead and pause that right there stop
the recording there you go and now here
we are in Wild Rift on the iPhone 14 pro
Max 60 FPS frame rate super high
graphics quality super high there high
on the FX post-processing and dynamic
off everything identical to the s22
ultra let's do some Aram honestly guys
the speaker difference alone is huge
like oh just even balance between the
earpiece and the bottom speaker
completely different than the s22 which
is just so out of balance and just the
quality big Improvement run no come on
man still sitting up really good FPS
just like the s22 we're sitting at
basically 59 to 60 FPS
we're having no issues with brightness
so sometimes I am seeing it go down to
like 52.55 wow I was not expecting that
on the iPhone really interesting we're
kind of getting wrecked guys give me
somebody fun Lucy in yeah
[Music]
oh he wrecked me so just like the s22
ultra no issues yet in terms of
performance
no all right well that was that around
20 minutes there let's go ahead and stop
that recording and now for the rest of
the time that we have the rest of the
hour about 20 minutes left we're gonna
play gentian so we just got in we're
still at maximum brightness super nice
and bright no issues at all however the
FPS unlike the other two games we're
setting out what is that 43 46 42 FPS
right off the bat it is lower now let me
show you the graphic settings that we
have we're at custom with everything set
to basically the highest 60 FPS motion
blur is ah so what is like insanely high
in terms of the FPS and we'll see if it
goes up or down over time and we
definitely are not getting 60 FPS in
this game so I guess we'll see what if
the iPhone 14 pro Max gets a solid 60.
that'll be interesting and I do feel the
frame starting to drop up a bit now 45
definitely doesn't feel perfectly smooth
oh that's so annoying look
so easy to block the speakers it seems
like we actually got some dimming guys
because I'm getting dropped frames right
now oh grab that yeah I got the crystal
core yep it is definitely dimmer let me
see if it actually reflected that
over here no look it's still
however oh look how much it dimmed
look if you adjust it like this it just
stops getting brighter so the s22 is
definitely dimmed and it is hot the back
is getting
really really hot actually you could see
sea temp right here it shows 61 degrees
Celsius right there
it's probably the chip temp which is
cool that on it Android you have the USB
debugging mode 63 degrees Celsius it's
getting hot and it has dimmed officially
we'll have to see what dims more I'll do
a side-by-side comparison with the
iPhone after playing this
[Music]
all right looking at
FP still at about oh I just saw 38 right
there 44 36 nowhere near 60 FPS man so
the display has definitely dimmed down
still very hot and we're still getting
pretty low FPS look at the brightness
look I'm adjusting it like this no
difference until we see about right here
this is where you see a difference but
at the high end no difference at all
that means it dims down to around what
is that like 50 brightness is dimming
down to yep and there you guys go it has
now been a full hour as you guys can see
242 and let me go ahead and turn off the
FPS counter and the Moment of Truth
we're looking at 80 battery life on the
s22 ultra after a full hour of gaming
and the display did Dim down all right
now here we are in gention on the iPhone
let me go into the graphic settings as
you can see the same as on the s22 ultra
everything basically to the highest
60fps with motion blur turned off
getting right into it brightness is nice
and super bright we'll see if it dims
over time
oh it actually undimmed it was a little
bit dim but look it undimmed that was
kind of odd wow look at that FPS guys 57
56 I even saw 60 right there
what the s22 was at like 45-ish
no it does have its occasional dips but
honestly I don't even think it hit 44
yet or 40 like the uh s22 did very good
performance so far uh oh who's this dude
oh snap man vaporize you and then imma
wreck you boom and surprisingly usually
at this moment I feel like the uh old
iPhone 13 Pro Max would already dim it's
actually a very good gaming experience
so far are you kidding me I just died
man still great FPS speakers sound
awesome wow guys it's like barely
dimming this did not happen on the 13
Pro Max guys
oh oh there you go it just dimmed I was
feeling to get hot I wonder if this is
darker than the s22 all right and there
you go it's been just over an hour 4 25
on the iPhone we're looking at 82
battery life and with that said the
iPhone also beats it in a lot of the
battery tests so we can do more with the
remaining 82 compared to 80 on the s22
ultra and there you guys go that was our
gameplay and now let's get into the
final conclusion which phone is better
at gaming well looking at the battery
life results after one hour of gaming on
each phone the s22 ultra ended at 80
percent while the iPhone ended at 82 so
it's pretty close however the iPhone
does win a lot of the battery tests by a
good margin so the iPhone is still the
battery champ for gaming now let's look
at the FPS before we talk about the
dimming so here we are on perfdog's
website and by the way it's currently 20
off so use the link below if you're
interested it's not working to open the
actual data sheet for some reason so I'm
just going to use this main page now on
the s22 ultra in Call of Duty we had
55.7 FPS compared to 53.1 on the iPhone
14 pro Max which is pretty interesting
it might be because it goes down to 30
FPS in the menu so maybe I spent more
time loading and waiting in the menu so
it's basically around the same with the
s22 ultra being a little bit better then
we have wild Rift 58.9 for the s22 ultra
and 58.3 for the iPhone so it's just
ever so slightly better on the s22 but
here's the main difference gen impact
the s22 had 43.7 average FPS compared to
57.5 and that was the really really
demanding game so with that said overall
the iPhone takes the k cake for FPS
right there in genshen huge difference
and seeing as it won in the battery life
test as well that is very impressive
that it got more FPS overall and then
finally in terms of display dimming both
phones had absolutely zero issues in
Call of Duty and wild Rift however in
genshin Impact both of them dimmed down
and maybe the iPhone did get a little
bit darker just right there at the end
of my testing but the s22 ultra did Dim
down almost to around 50 percent so
they're basically the same and taken all
of that together combining the FPS the
battery life and the dimming I would say
that the iPhone 14 pro Max is definitely
the winner and it is the best gaming
phone especially since there are more
games that support 120 FPS than on
Android so this takes the cake if you
totally disagree with me then let me
know down in the comment section below
and if you enjoyed the video click the
circle above to subscribe for more
videos like this one thanks for watching
and we'll see you in the next one
[Music]